you should fight one another for the
honor of leadership
not necessarily everybody knows who's in
charge
me yes you
of course of course of course
hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my video for thor 4
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or as
guardians of the galaxy as we should
call it unofficially thor
iv we know a little bit about the plot
and the characters of the movie in the
story arc so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the marvel
videos
we're also doing a new round of that
imax ticket giveaway like we have the
new cut of avengers endgame hitting
theaters and spiderman far from home
you can use the tickets for any movie
that you want all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
thor or spider-man comment on the video
i'll name a new winner at the end of
this
so we just broke this down top 7 style
starting with
rockets supposedly the movie is going to
be dealing with his backstory james gunn
said that he
identifies with rocket most as a
character and at one time when he was
doing guardians 2
he thought about doing a rocket groot
spin-off if he was ever going to do a
spin-off of any of the guardians
characters
so it makes sense that they would deal
with a lot of rockets backstory in one
of these films
but supposedly the person who created
him in the mcu
will be the high evolutionary who's a
really weird and super deep cut avengers
villain from the comics
the guardians films pride themselves
trading on really weird characters
inside the mcu talking raccoon talking
trees so the high evolutionary is not a
big leap for them to make during the
film
impressive you're far more vibrant than
my usual subjects
i'll show you vibrant red you will
address me
as the high evolutionary thanos's rock
forget it do your worst we ain't telling
you
squat i am no torturer
i am an artist terrible fathers are also
a running theme through all of the films
gamora's terrible dad in the first film
is thanos
peter quill's terrible dad ego the
living planet is the villain of the
second film
it would make sense that another
terrible dad would be one of the
villains of the third film and it just
so happens to be rocket's creator
if you're not really familiar with
rocket's backstory in the marvel comics
he was actually from half world
but you also saw that during the lineup
during the first guardians film where
you see he's from half world but they
don't really get into his backstory
it was a planet in the universe where a
bunch of alien humanoids
they built a planet to be an insane
asylum to watch and treat study a bunch
of people
they wound up leaving but they left
behind a race of robots to care for all
the insane people on the planet
a nearby explosion on a star created all
this radiation
the robots gained sentience then they
themselves started experimenting in
upgrading the animals that had been left
behind as companions for the formerly
insane humans that the planet had been
originally created for
it's a really weird story obviously the
high evolutionary isn't part of the
comic book version of that so they're
already changing some of rocket's comic
book backstory so don't worry
too much about that right now six
they're supposed to use the rocket
backstory plot with the high
evolutionary to introduce the lila
character from the comics she's a
talking otter in the way that rocket is
a talking raccoon
she's supposed to be his soul mate and
she's the heir to one of the largest
companies
on their home world there was a story in
the comics where they saved all the
creations on their home planet then they
flew away together on a spaceship to
live out their lives
so maybe rocket winds up getting a happy
ending of sorts and winds up leaving the
guardians at the end of the film
the team's roster is going to cycle
anyway if they continue as a group
within the mcu
regardless of whether or not they do
guardians of the galaxy vol 4.
but number five drax is supposed to
learn that his daughter is still alive
so presumably his arc in the film would
be reuniting with her and
going off to be a family again so maybe
he also leaves the guardians team at the
end of the film
because batista is getting up there in
age and just like hugh jackman said that
it was just
spine crushing to stay in shape to play
the wolverine character
it's the same deal for dave bautista
playing drax
it is really really hard for him to stay
in that good of shape the physical toll
that it takes on his body just
performing as the character
if you've ever heard the nightmare that
it is to get into drax makeup and then
out of drax makeup you would also assume
that in relative short order drax would
get his happy ending and sort of right
off into the sunset so i don't expect
him to stay on the guardians team for
forever
heard zoe saldana's a makeup regime
yesterday yours is pretty involved as
well involves a sauna and shaving cream
oh yeah
yeah it does so that's the remove so
yeah the great part about it is it goes
on very fast about an hour and a half
which is it was great for me the first
one was like four to six hours
the bad part is that it's it's very
abrasive it's like glue
so to get it off i have to sit in a
sauna for about an hour
and so what we do is first they they rub
shaving cream all over me because it
helps to loosen up the makeup it's
really it's really it's really awful
it's
we've gotten some strange looks but so i
got my team they rub shaver came all
over me
now i get in the sauna for about 20
minutes by myself and then they about
three guys join me
and they start you know scrubbing this
makeup remember the only reason he
joined the guardians in the first
film was to kill thanos as revenge for
thanos killing his family and as of the
end of avengers end game
both versions of thanos are dead goal 1
achieved and 2
if his daughter were still alive it
would really complete his arc
the story about him getting out of
costume though is insane so obviously it
takes a long time to put the drax
makeup on before while looking for the
younger gamora from 2014
remember peter quill is trying to track
her down as the end of avengers end game
nebula chills out even more and grows
closer with peter quill and the other
guardians
i don't think that there's anything
romantically that's going to be going on
between the two of them but remember
what gamora's character arc was in the
first and second guardians films
she starts out as this super hardcore
person betrays thanos then begrudgingly
joins the guardians of the galaxy
because they need each other's help to
prevent the power stone from falling
into thanos hands
then by the second film she's officially
part of the family
and even acting like a very hardcore mom
and dad team with peter
quill all the while trying to get her
sister nebula to chill out and join the
cool kids for super fun happy times
so after i murder my sister i will buy
worship with every conceivable
instrument of death
i will hunt my father like a dog and i
will tear him apart slowly
peace by peace until he knows some
semblance of the profound and unceasing
pain
i know every single day
yeah this time it would be nebula as the
cool kid chasing after angry or gamora
to try and get her to chill out and join
the family
i was a huge fan of the brief iron man
and nebula scenes that we got during
avengers end game karen gillan is
awesome as that character
so no idea if nebula and gamora would
leave the team at the end of the movie
maybe nebula stays on because i think
that karen gillan really enjoys playing
that character and i think that they've
found easier ways to get her into makeup
so it's not quite as brutal as say like
drax's makeup
three thor is supposed to be part of the
movie as guardians of the galaxy as
implied by this ending scene from
avengers end game
but the way dave batista talked about
chris hemsworth recently
makes me wonder how much of the movie
he's supposed to be part of because
remember
james gunn turned in his final script
for the movie a couple years ago before
that big debacle happened before we knew
anything about what was going on during
avengers end game and where they were
taking the thor
character so dave bautista recently said
i would love to have chris hemsworth as
thor
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3. so i'm
like wait a minute is thor
actually in the original version of the
movie that james gunn wrote or are they
changing things are they adding him
later what's the deal odds are because
people like thor so much with guardians
of the galaxy that maybe he's not a huge
part of the film he just a small part or
the at least reference what's going on
and then he goes off on his own by the
end of the film and they use it as a
sort of jumping off point for whatever
thor 4
is going to be once they eventually make
that movie two this is really cool
supposedly the movie is finally going to
do a version of beta ray bill who we
last
saw as an easter egg during thor
ragnarok he was actually originally in a
cut of that film but they took him out
at the last minute so he is a character
in the mcu he does exist and he's still
alive
no idea what the future of beta ray bill
within the thor franchise is going to be
or if beta ray bill would become a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
just because those films trade on weird
characters so much and beta ray bill is
one of the weirdest
characters that they would have ever
done so far i think if he continues as a
character in the mcu and thor 4 and
whatever other space based films
it just depends on how much people like
the character during guardians 3.
it is always possible he could wind up
being another deleted scene too
so my beta ray bill expectations are
actually pretty low
but he's a member of the corbonite race
in the comics he was originally
introduced by walt simonsen
to be the first non-asgardian thor
character
to be deemed worthy enough to lift
thor's hammer that was the whole idea
somebody else who could finally lift
thor's hammer
[Music]
after he does odin winds up forging him
his own hammer that has similar powers
to mjolnir
and he just goes off on his adventures
with thor showing up every once in a
while
the hammer itself is called stormbreaker
so because
thor's new axe hammer in the mcu is
called stormbreaker
maybe they'll have some fun with that
idea the thor ragnarok beta ray build
deleted scenes were just him
fighting in the arena planet hulk style
remember his face was on the side of the
grand master's tower meaning that he's
one of the previous
champions of the contest of champions
kevin feige said that they did a lot of
previz and he was in a version of the
movie right up to the end
but they just felt like there was too
much going on so they just wound up
cutting him out so that they could
introduce him in a much bigger way in
another marvel movie
rather than worry that they do him a
disservice as a character by only just
briefly showing him on screen and that's
it not really explaining anything about
the character
so even though he was in the movie for a
long time he wasn't
ever going to be a really big part of it
in number one of course the movie is
supposed to introduce adam warlock we
all saw that during the guardians of the
galaxy
vol 2 post-credits scene first is the
villain because he's being created by
the sovereign who are villains to the
guardians of the galaxy
and then eventually their ally because
even if you're not an expert on adam
warlock comics you probably know that
he's mostly a good character in the
comics
but you can see how introducing him as a
villain and antagonist to the guardians
at first is a way to reference his mages
persona from the comics there's rumors
that it's supposed to be zac efron i
don't totally believe that but they
probably have someone in mind because
originally they were supposed to start
shooting guardians 3 this past january
before that big debacle happened
so they would have had to have already
been talking to people about playing the
character
but with the delay it's not coming till
2022 now
they could continue the search and as
much as everyone is thinking about keanu
reeves is adam warlock i don't think
that that's what they're talking to
keanu reeves about
you're breathtaking you're all
breathtaking they've been talking to
candy reeves about playing a character
in the marvel cinematic universe kevin
feige said that they've talked to keanu
reeves
every year about every single marvel
movie they've ever made to try and find
something for him to do because he's so
fantastic and right now he's blowing
up of course they want to get him in the
mcu somewhere
oh yeah ha ha yes
hold on one more oh
yeah i think he would make an amazing
adam warlock but i just i don't think
that they're going for him
it's just the idea that adam warlock is
a very spiritual character
but because of the spiritual characters
that kiana reeves is known for playing
you can understand how people would be
theorycrafting that maybe adam warlock
is the character that he's up for
possible outcome for the guardians at
the end of the movie though is that a
new roster forms around either
thor or permanent as guardians of the
galaxy in thor 4 or maybe thor leaves at
the end an adam warlock winds up forming
a new team of guardians
presumably teenage groot would finally
grow to become full-sized adult root
again his race doesn't age like normal
humanoids he can grow to full size any
time he wants he just needs the
sustenance to give himself
energy for the change so i would expect
that the guardians as a team
will continue on but the roster will be
very different
they've been talking about doing a nova
film during marvel phase four it's
always possible that they use the
guardians movies to spin that character
out unless it's going to be some big
prequel movie it is a little too early
to start introducing fantastic four
silver surfer galactus characters but
silver surfer would be an
awesome thor iv crossover so hopefully
they'll find some way in the next couple
of movies to introduce that character
there'll be a whole bunch more marvel
stuff happening next week i'll do a post
credit scene video for the new cut of
avengers endgame and obviously i'll be
doing spider-man videos all week long
leave your requests in the comments
below congratulations anthony jordan
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details
click here for my new avengers endgame
post credit scene video
and click here for that funny new
spider-man far from home scene and learn
all about the spider-man venom crossover
teaser from kevin feige
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight